[Music]
nearly all billionaires are seen as
hard-working
innovative inspirations bezos
revolutionized online shopping
jobs redefined the phone and zuckerberg
connected people
on a never-before-seen level using the
internet
but at the same time virtually all of
these guys
also get mounds of criticism for being
slave drivers
unsympathetic jerks and um lizards
however one mega billionaire who avoids
most of this criticism
is elon musk so is there a dark side to
elon musk
before we get started here i just wanted
to make it clear
that this video is by no means intended
to be hate towards elon musk
he has achieved outstanding feats in a
variety of different fields
and has no doubt done more good than bad
at least in my opinion in this video we
are simply taking a look
at some of the biggest things that many
people dislike about billionaires
and seeing whether or not they applied
to elon musk as well
with that being said to answer this
question we have to first
outline the top areas of criticism for
billionaires
which include labor exploitation
avoiding social slash
economic responsibility and unethical
business practices
taking a look at labor exploitation this
is something that all major companies
involved with manufacturing and
logistics take part in
40 of all electronics in the world come
from one factor in china
called foxconn and the average foxconn
factory worker
gets paid just sixteen 390.16 per month
even at just forty hours per week their
hourly rate comes out to a mere two
dollars
and forty four cents but considering
that they often work
fifty to sixty hours the reality is
closer to just
two dollars an hour and yes this
includes trillion dollar corporations
such as apple amazon and microsoft
today it's essentially impossible to buy
mainstream electronics without
indirectly participating
in labor exploitation as for elon musk
his main companies are very much
involved in manufacturing
and logistics considering that they have
to build and move
cars as well as rockets but the saving
grace for elon's companies
is that his manufacturing can't really
be outsourced
and thus he is able to keep it in-house
without losing a competitive advantage
so the average tesla and spacex factory
worker
is paid drastically more than the
average chinese factory worker
used by other mega corporations
currently
at tesla the average hourly rate for
manufacturing workers
is in the high teens this is aside from
production supervisor
which is more of a managerial role an
hourly rate of eighteen to twenty
dollars
converts to about thirty seven thousand
to forty thousand dollars per year
as for spacex their annual wages are
generally much better
at fifty thousand to ninety thousand
dollars so
these guys are actually paid quite well
but we also have to keep in mind that
the average manufacturing worker
at spacex is not really comparable to
the average factory worker
as they are literally putting together
rockets considering this
both of elon's major companies pay their
manufacturing employees
quite respectably however this isn't to
say
that working the manufacturing units at
these companies is the most pleasant
as they are working pretty hard elon
musk
has commented that 80 hours per week is
required to change the world
and it seems like he does implement this
role within his companies
as it's quite common to hear 100 hour
work weeks on the regular from tesla
and spacex also i don't think they get
any overtime pay for this work either
considering that neither company can
really afford to do so
so given that they generally work double
their regular working hours
tesla's manufacturing workers actually
only get about 9 to 10 dollars per hour
at the end of the day the question of
labor exploitation
isn't really a black and white matter
though as while these employees
are paid nearly minimum wage per hour
most of these guys
were well aware of this before joining
and they often do extra work
willingly with that being said from an
objective standpoint
there is a component of labor
exploitation within musk's companies
but you can be the judge of how bad you
think this is
moving on to social responsibility this
is one of the top criticisms of many
corporations
especially in the energy and oil
industries
this argument of course originates from
pollution concerns regarding these
companies activities
elon musk generally excels in this area
as he is one of the largest proponents
of switching to clean energy
to be fair though battery production is
estimated to emit 150
to 200 kilograms of co2 per kilowatt
hour of battery capacity
this is up to 74 more than emissions
related to efficient conventional car
production however
over the long term the general consensus
is that switching to electric cars
will massively reduce co2 emissions so
tesla gets the green flag but there is
one concern with the space company
which is the massive amounts of
pollution released by each rocket launch
currently rocket-related co2 emissions
only account for
0.00059 percent of global co2 emissions
commercializing space flight though as
elon musk plans to do
may increase rocket pollution closer to
aviation levels of about 2.4 percent
this is still just a couple of
percentage points but
as pollution from other industries
decline rocket launches
may actually grow to several percentage
points so today
rocket launches are not a big deal in
terms of pollution
but in a couple of decades from now it
might be something we should focus on
next up we have economic responsibility
and
in this realm elon musk as well as his
companies
are no doubt guilty people love to
criticize jeff bezos for making tens of
billions per year
while paying nearly no taxes but this
is absolutely the same case with elon
musk
their respective wealths fluctuates with
the stock market
however they have for the most part made
approximately the same amount of money
this year with jeff bezos standing at
plus 74.1 billion
and elon musk standing at plus 74.4
billion
moreover amazon is near the end of its
growth curve
while spacex and tesla are just at the
beginning
thus 74.4 billion is likely
on the lower end of what musk will make
in the upcoming decade
also jeff bezos receives no stock
compensation
while elon musk will cash out on tens of
billions of dollars in stock
compensation
as tesla continues to grow elon musk
will literally
receive 1 4 of tesla for every 50
billion
increase in tesla's valuation and when
you're talking about a company worth
hundreds of billions of dollars
one percent is absolutely no joke and of
course
virtually all of elon's wealth gains
will be thanks to a stock ownership
which he will likely not sell meaning
that he'll end up paying nearly zero
income taxes on the tens of billions
he's making every year
despite this his companies receive
billions of dollars in funding from
taxpayers
the only reason spacex is alive today is
arguably funding
from nasa and as for tesla
well it's no question that they've
received hundreds of millions
if not billions in tax incentives over
the years
in fact the only reason that tesla is
even profitable today
is because of a government mandate
requiring other crime manufacturers to
either produce more electric vehicles
or buy regulatory credits from large ev
producers
which is basically just tesla sure you
could argue that tesla would still be
profitable without the regulatory
credits
as they would likely invest less without
this revenue source
but i think you get the point that i'm
trying to make also
as neither tesla nor spacex have been
very profitable for most of their lives
it's clear that elon musk as well as his
companies have paid very little in taxes
but they have massively benefited from
the government
finally moving on to unethical business
practices
generally this relates the company's
histories with fraud
deceit scams and things along those
lines
but today unnatural business practices
have taken on a different form
with tech companies companies such as
google and
facebook aren't generally criticized for
running scams
rather they're generally criticized for
invasion of privacy
suppression of certain people and
censorship in general
neither tesla nor spacex are infamous
for any of these criticisms
but it could be argued that musk's
tweets are not fair for investors
of his companies in the past elon musk
has been charged with securities fraud
and was forced to step down as cessless
chairman
but despite this elon musk has continued
to push the limits when it comes to
taunting
and teasing tesla short sellers many of
you guys would argue that bulls
and bears investing in tesla sign up for
musk's tweets
as well and i completely agree people
looking to invest in tesla should be
ready for any fluctuations in stock
price
caused by musk tweets however we also
have to keep in mind that tesla
is a public company and that the ceo of
a public company should
act accordingly despite how frustrating
tesla bears may be
they should have a fair opportunity to
short sell tesla if that is what they
want
given that tesla is a public company so
it can be argued that elon's tweeting is
unfair and
unethical to a degree considering all of
this
elon musk does possess some of the
characteristics that are criticized to
death
for other billionaires employees at his
companies
are worked pretty rigorously for
relatively small pay
spacex and tesla aren't as
environmentally friendly
as they might seem at first glance elon
makes tens of billions per year
and his companies have massively
benefited from the government
while him and his companies pay very
little in taxes
and finally his tweets aren't very fair
to certain types of investors
in tesla but as i said at the beginning
elon's contributions to the ev space ai
and transportation industries
exponentially outweigh these drawbacks
in my opinion however i would say the
same thing
about jeff bezos and all the other top
billionaires as well
so i guess my opinion doesn't mean too
much in this realm
anyways what do you guys think about the
quote unquote dark side
of elon musk comment that down below
also if you would like to suggest future
video ideas then consider checking out
our community discord
and of course if you guys think elon's
pros far outweigh his cons
then drop a like and consider
subscribing to see more questions
logically answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys
on the next one
you